it is so good to see you you have had an
incredible year does it feel that way
for you
it's yeah it's been it's been a little
crazy but very very exciting I want to
recap the last year a little bit so
almost a year ago to the day the All Too
Well short film was released and a
moment in pop culture history was sealed
forever but now it's being talked about
in terms of an Oscar Nom and I'm just
curious what that would mean to you to
see that film nominated or even win I
would love that for Taylor personally as
a fan of her I I would love to see her
do that
um yeah that's that's very exciting
um and yeah I'm very honored to be have
contributed to that short film the top
comment on that video by the way is
Sadie literally looks like as if Autumn
were a person
well that's funny so thank you I
appreciate it have you settled on a
favorite midnight track yet
oh man okay I've been going back and
forth thank you for asking this thank
you
um I think right now like top two are
Labyrinth and uh
this glitch which is one of the
additional tracks but I'm really liking
glitch but Labyrinth and glitch are my
two favorite at the moment the list just
like keeps evolving it's gonna change
for the next month that's just it's what
happens when a new album comes up but
yeah if you had to be in one of the
videos which one would you want to be in
oh for midnights yeah
[Music]
um
maybe Karma
Karma would be a fun one I think when we
get to the summer and we have the very
Max Centric Kate Bush ee season of
stranger things yes I want to ask you
because we recently found out that Max
was actually supposed to die at the end
of season four
this was news to me I remember when when
the Matt and Ross said this in an
interview yeah that was that was news
but um I I think I think I'm glad I'm
glad she she's still alive technically
or she's in some kind of in-between
state right now I'm not sure but yeah
that that was that was shocking news to
me oh my god did you talk to them after
me like hey what gifts
no I think I I understand I understand
when when you're on a show like this
like you're that's kind of what you're
in for like you're you're you don't know
if you're gonna make it ah have you
began to process the
the ending of the show
I've
yeah if I think about it too much I get
really sad it's just been such a huge
part of all of our lives and I think
we're going to be really sad to say
goodbye to these characters and to this
cast and crew
um because there's really there's this
like security knowing that like you're
always going to go back for another
season so now that you know we won't
have that anymore that's it's going to
be really sad to say goodbye but I mean
what a what a journey I mean it's been
incredible dear Zoe out November 4th
this book is is so good it was red it's
read in schools now as a way to help
like you know young people deal with
grief what does it mean for you to be a
part of this film
yeah I think it's it's really really
special
um I read the book first and really fell
in love with it um so it was um an honor
to bring it to life
um and yeah I didn't know that they're
reading it in schools that's really nice
I think everybody's process is different
and
um
yeah I think I think this this movie
explores like a teenage girls experience
with grief
um and
yeah it's it's definitely a hard time
um and yeah
yeah I test like I I love that she kind
of expresses herself through ART I'm
curious also if you kept any of those
drawings because they were very
beautiful of you I wasn't allowed I
asked and I was not allowed and I
thought that was rude I was like man
there was one that was so that I loved
so much
um but I was not allowed to keep it
unfortunately it's like that's my
likeness I know
[Music]